To finish typing the rest of this inequality, you should have entered a
backslash, the letters le, a space, the letter b, another backslash, and an le,
and another space, and then the number 2. This last one is really complicated.
But hopefully, you stayed with it and figured it out. First, we type a
backslash, the letters inf, and a space for this infinity symbol. Then, we use a
backslash and the letters ge and a space for the greater than or equal to sign.
We have the letter x next, and then another backslash ge space for the greater
than or equal to sign. And finally, we finish out with a negative sign or
negative infinity, and a backslash letters, inf, and a space. This will give us
our last negative infinity. Feel free to play around with MathQuill and see if
you can type in some other things. We'll definitely be learning more about
MathQuill as we go.